foreign
[Music]
for Tuesday January 17th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
the next generation of rockets built to
launch U.S spy satellites are going to
have to meet some new requirements the
contractors building them will have to
show those Rockets are able to fend off
interference by China and Russia
according to people briefed on an
upcoming Pentagon competition
it's a sign of just how crucial
governments are viewing the use of space
and it comes as private competition to
supply Rockets satellites and launch
materials gets even fiercer with me to
discuss this is our Aerospace reporter
Micah maidenberg hi Micah great to have
you back on the show Hey Zoe great to be
here let's start off with this news
about the defense department preparing
to issue new requirements that rockets
that send up spy satellites to orbit be
able to fend off interference Micah why
is the Pentagon putting this into their
new rules well broadly speaking they're
putting it into this sort of space
launch Contracting round because defense
officials Pentagon leaders are
increasingly focused on China's
capabilities in space Russia's space
operations have also been drawing more
attention from military planners of late
in 2021 for example the country used a
missile to destroy one of its defunct
satellites and more recently Russian
officials have said that U.S commercial
satellites could be targeted if they
were found to be assisting Ukraine so if
you're the Pentagon and you're buying
rockets and you're putting highly
sensitive very expensive in some cases
satellites on those Rockets to go to
orbit you want some assurances that
those Vehicles can deliver the goods and
avoid potential threats you know or
hazards as they're providing that
Transportation if you will how are the
private companies that would be bidding
for these contracts reacting to this
kind of request so to be sure this is a
procurement this is the government the
Pentagon you know buying services from
companies and you know rocket companies
a lot of them have really been tracking
this very closely to see how the defense
department is going to kind of structure
this acquisition how they're going to
buy rocket launches and we're expecting
to get more details about that you know
as soon as next month but it's a it's a
big deal for of the industry because the
Pentagon is a big steady client and
commands a lot of prestige and
credibility and of course Revenue that
these companies are chasing after as
well I want to talk about one company in
particular that really stood out over
the last couple years that's Elon musk's
SpaceX it conducted 61 missions last
year and musk said back in August that
he wants to complete up to a hundred
this year Mike how big a deal would that
leap be and how does SpaceX plan to
accomplish that yeah I mean look 61
missions in 2022 was already a big deal
that was by far and away the most of any
private space company in the globe and
it represented call it about a third of
all orbital missions that reached orbit
last year so right just off the top 61
is is Big getting up to 100 would be
another big leap SpaceX has demonstrated
pretty strong capacity to both build
rockets and perhaps more importantly but
perhaps sometimes not discussed as much
like when they're reusable components of
those Rockets come back to earth
the company is very good at revamping
them getting them back into shape so
they can be quickly used again and so
part of it is getting from 61 to 100
orbital flights is that sort of on the
ground turnaround of the boosters that
listeners may remember or have seen
before online or or whatnot like coming
back to Earth and that's going to be a
big challenge to sort of do that almost
at a 100 times next year it's a lot of
work you don't have a lot of room for
error when you're trying to quickly turn
these around but that's the plan at
least how much competition does SpaceX
face when it's trying to do these
launches this year a lot of new rockets
are slated to come onto the market
United launch Alliance which is owned by
Lockheed Martin and Boeing is planning
to test fly its forthcoming vehicle
Vulcan Centaur relatively soon blue
origin has been pushing to get its new
Glenn rocket up and operational though
it's not clear if the company's going to
try to launch it this year and there's
other Rockets kind of in the work so
even as SpaceX pushes toward that up to
100 orbital flight goal for the year
other rocket companies are taking aim at
the market with their own fresh vehicles
to bring some more competition let me
ask you about another private company
virgin orbit last week it had a failed
mission to carry commercial satellites
to orbit from a new site in the UK can
you tell us Micah what happened and how
big a blow is this for Virgin orbit and
for the new UK site right so this
mission was a very high profile launch
of course recalled that virgin orbit
uses a modified Boeing 747 to fly a
launcher into the air where that
launcher then drops from the plane and
shoots off into orbit to deliver
satellites and what the company has said
so far is that the rocket was dropped it
reached sort of space altitude but at
some point like later in the mission
part of the rocket experienced an
anomaly and that anomaly prevented you
know the mission from being successful
and the satellites from being deployed
as expected the company hasn't said much
yet or provided much more details beyond
that they're still doing analysis of
data and investigating kind of what went
wrong the UK more generally hasn't been
launching the same kind of way as the US
and China which are by far and ahead out
front in terms of orbital missions and
this was the first orbital flight first
orbital launch from England and it
didn't work so it's not the outcome by
any means that virgin orbit and the
local Spaceport and other officials were
hoping for that's our Aerospace reporter
Micah maidenberg thanks for joining us
Micah thank you Zoe have a great one and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories check out our
website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]
[Music]